welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz Sam you
can't sit there last laugh I'm joined by
Sam Oakes I'm in Bristol Sam is one of
the founders of recruit UK and we're
gonna have a good chat around your
journey Sam max you're looking forward
to it
oh yeah of course yeah yeah absolutely
yes so as we were just saying we're
always like to start Sam is how you got
into recruitment because I think
obviously from what I can see online and
your LinkedIn and stuff it seems like
you haven't been on the typical
recruitment journeys so how did you
enter the world of recruitment and so I
got into I got into recruitment through
I was 27 years old when I first got into
recruitment so a lot older than I think
most people tend to think most people
tend to get on the graduate route yeah
and to recruitment around about 21 but I
was 27 and I was working for a financial
services company so Aviva yeah so I was
looking for Aviva
I'm part of a joint venture with the
Royal Bank of Scotland okay I was there
for about nearly five years and when I
was there I was working as a customer
service consultant talking to financial
advisors and customers of the bank yeah
about their pensions investments
protection products and from there I
moved in like a team leader role and
then became a trainer
financial services trainer so I was
training out the financial products to
newbies that were coming into the into
the company yeah because obviously they
would sell products that you will see
not the guys on the phones that I was
talking to they were more customer
service so the actual people were out in
the market would be selling products at
you guys but yeah yeah the joint venture
was you know Aviva Aviva sold their
products through the Royal Bank of
Scotland yeah so financial advisors
would sell Aviva products yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so pensions investments and protection
all that kind of stuff so my job was to
really make that interesting for
somebody who is like 18 19 20 years old
without any experience or understanding
of well you know certain legislations
around pension transfers a day and all
these different changes and bonds and
how the footsies work footsie works and
all that kind of stuff so I'd have
really good
standing of financial services it sure
has been quite interesting I really
liked it it was creative so I just have
to create training programs that kind of
stuff so I was doing all of that really
but you know it didn't really fulfill me
mmm so that's interesting whilst I was
in that role you know I was you only
ever are as good as you am yearn as much
as the Machine lets you hmm
so I couldn't you know the forties 50 60
K so I was the guy I wanted to earn that
all my friends were earning at the age
of 27
some of my friends were starting to
learn some really good money hmm i felt
quite restricted with it so i felt quite
so limited limited into why could what i
could actually hit a glass ceiling has
we all yeah and by candidates yeah and
it wasn't it was just very big business
and I think my mind Sen Who I am as a
person
I was quite creative and I always wanted
to try to change the way the training
programs were put across but in if you
understand working in financial services
you've got lots of people telling you
you can't say certain things loads of
red tape so you get really kind of like
downtrodden a little bit yeah and forced
races so um yeah that point it was like
right well I think we want to do this
anymore say I was outing a beer actually
and with a friend of mine and I was
whinging and moaning over the table I
wanted to work that I was fed up if not
only enough money yeah body body blah
and that I would like to get into
recruitment and whoa where'd that come
from where did they come from
yeah well why recruitment I'd always
wanted there's always something in the
back of my mind that said working
recruitment really yeah it says you have
friends and recruitment no actually why
the hell was that comfortable Bristol
was full of recruitment companies really
yeah and the thing is it's go backwards
because I was when I was younger I
always did sales roles okay so because I
saw you as an insurance self yeah I'll
start my sales career really yeah so I
was it Cornhill direct selling insurance
for a few years outbound selling
insurance house contents and all that
kind of stuff yeah it was a hard old
slog yeah and before that I did some
awful bloody sales jobs I saw windows to
people over the telephone when I was
like 16 17 years old I knocked on
people's doors
doing door-to-door sales for like two
half years so I really cut meat and a
half years and a half years I built like
a little team it's like pyramid selling
basically May that's it's really
interesting to say this so as of just
saying that they obviously also done a
podcast with Jack call from Mefford and
he did door-to-door sells for 18 months
and we like that so long that song
because you do it typically is like two
months three months he's committed in
two and a half years yeah and
interesting enough actually the types of
people that I've bumped into since then
have all gone on to run their own
businesses and really make runs up like
a personal trees a personal trainer and
have one of my mates in the recruitment
company and then that went under
actually did it tend to tended to go on
do something okay that's very much so
the resource where that came from and
asked that question was well hang on
actually I've had a ton of experience
doing sales and I've ended up in this
training role so then so then literally
at that point mmm you started recruit UK
no okay say at that point well yes so
when I was little at the table the
person who was on the other side of the
table Stuart sure okay any pass favorite
business card we said well if you
weren't even working with Krugman why
don't you come in and see me on Monday
I own a recruitment company and we'll
have a chat okay now that recruitment
company on his business card was a
company called Viridian Viridian
Viridian okay now the really owner were
a recruitment agency that had appointed
representatives working for them across
the UK so self-employed were clearing
concerns with plug into Viridian and
Meridian had always contracts with all
the major banks so they would just farm
out all their vacancies to all these
self-employed guys and take a you know a
30% split on everything that these guys
were doing now Stuart was Stuart was
originally employed by Veridian
but there in SAP wasn't then had to set
up as a self-employed AR of them mm-hmm
downstairs so when I came along and
joined recruit UK was just a name on a
piece of paper say it was just a name on
a piece of paper a limited company could
recruit UK but they took all the
branding of Viridian and used their
branding and their name and everything
and only really just filled the roles
that Viridian generated because they had
loads of financial adviser positions at
the
thanks ya later Mortgage Advice
positions customer advisors all that
kind of stuff see methylates vacancies
you didn't need to go out so there's a
kind of beautiful little suburb really
you would do this going candidate
generate and give away 30 percent of
where is you wrote okay so just to be
clear then so it's I'm not sure I just
want to make sure I fully understand
that yeah so when you obviously when you
was mining about you want to get into
recruitment or not okay in joining a job
that was Stewart yeah shoot handed you a
business card yeah yeah right and then
no she came in on Monday yeah next you
it yeah and you just said this the
original setup was the obviously these
banks had loads of vacancies they found
him out to Rhydian
yeah Viridian then had people like
Stewart and other people cost you go
across the UK that could obviously fill
this job yeah just explain the recruiter
so then where did the where does recruit
UK fit into this pre-k was an appointed
representative of Viridian okay
and now should do it and that was Stuart
another guy called Lee so there was two
of them had said it yeah and they had a
couple of people that were they started
to employee within their little branch
if you like okay that my sentence and
then starts they started to actually
expand yeah grown obviously AR I'm so
familiar with that in insurance as well
because that's a similar cell okay so
we'll see and how long was Stuart doing
that for them was usually quite early on
because obviously you and Stuart now own
yeah so he was doing out for bad about a
year before my joins but he was working
in recruitment before that as well so he
used to work for another company selling
sorry doing like construction
recruitment on the Osprey bases which
sounded horrific yeah you did that but
and then now how long is really keeping
them for about eleven and a half years
I'm doing it from at eleven a half years
say maybe about twelve and a half years
something like that and then so then
just just give me the sort of logistics
and when did you end when did it cuz
you're now 50/50 partners right yeah
and was that a journey to get to that
point in a machine man how did that
happen there was that straight off the
bat that's all no no no say yeah see
when I came into the when I came into
Viridian we were working on I came into
work on an RBS akane I've got a net load
of vacancies right at that point I
joined was the credit crunch oh wow so
all the bank's died closing up and
clowning up and saying that we're not
giving any more vacancies out see
Stewart when white basically just you
know just employed me and sort of
thinking [ __ ] what we're gonna get him
to do now yeah but anyway I came in and
I just sort of picked at the I just kind
of I knew that recruitment is gonna be
tough and I knew is gonna be hard and I
knew that I had to make a little
outbound calls and all of that and back
on my history of working in smash into
telephones trying to sell people windows
I just got on the phone and started
speaking to people but we generated a
one client when we were generating a lot
of vacancies off the back of Veridian
yeah
I mean I was a big building Society and
I ended up doing a load of business in
my first year through this one building
Society really they literally gave me
one vacancy as a part-time role up in
like North London and I just were nuts
off of it for like a fee of about two
thousand quid
yes but I really cut my teeth on that I
really started to understand the
structure of what you need to do in
recruitment to be able to find really
good candidates and the client
relationship and all of that kind of
stuff so was this night doing that I
started getting really good at the
credit crunch was sort of fade out a
little bit we started getting more and
more vacancies through the banks and I
started doing a lot of work then through
RBS and making lots of placements in my
second year I did about 150 grand yeah
but there still wasn't enough vacancies
out there yeah along those lines
so I ended up at the time though the
business wasn't really making lots and
lots of money we didn't have loads of
people employed and there were some okay
recruiters in there yeah
the Stuart ended up getting a hundred
percent of the business bye-bye
the other chap leaving yeah yeah and he
got some situation where I think I was
probably bidding the most on the board
so he was paying me the most so is a bit
like well we better make him a 50%
shareholder in the business okay and
that's how it happened yeah yeah it
wasn't like yeah I wasn't fighting for
it because at the time I was just I was
only recruitment consultant and you know
I was just a couple years in and I was
just making some and I was 11 years ago
but man yeah I must admit about 2 or 3
years whilst I got in so about three
years maybe two and a half I'm not very
good with dates you have to that's all
right yeah about two and a half freezes
but you've been a 50% shareholder for
about seven years now yeah yeah that's
really interested in that I kind of fell
into it I kind of yes it just it just it
was an opportunity came up to me and
said do you want to be a director within
this business and I said yeah you know
and because have you ever won in your
own business
no yeah there's always me in the back of
my mind that wants it
my own business I'm quite sort of that
way inclined anyway I always an had in
my head that I was going to achieve
something that I was gonna own something
I'm I am somebody that I quite like
control and snowing quite I always
thought I was gonna have something that
was gonna be mine a pyramid scheme
pyramid
[Laughter]
okay so that's really interesting then
select why don't we why don't we break
that down a bit then so I guess I said
the first thing what I always like to
sort of just just touch on before we go
into the sort of last seven eight years
of you yeah being a real percent
shareholder this business so you were
talking about it there but so first 12
months and recruitment mmm more they're
like first 12 months yes well there's a
recession recession hit was it just
laughs there or I think you have a
perception don't you for agreement
before you get into it if what you think
it is and then the reality of it it's
completely different
do you think I'm going up all these
vacancies and all these people are gonna
walk through my door and I'm just gonna
sit down with them and chat with them
and find them a job and it's gonna be
nice and easy you don't realise just how
tough and hard it actually isn't how
competitive it is and how you go out and
source those candidates and what the
candidate experiences and what their
thoughts are off actually your
recruitment consultant mmm you know um
so my first year was tough yeah like I
think the first year for anybody games
into recruitment is tough you know you
have to blood sweat and tears and I
would often sort of take myself out to
the toilet and sit in the toilet be
sitting shaking thinking like what am I
doing this for this is this is horrible
why didn't you quit cuz I don't quit I'm
not a quitter
so and and also as well I observed
within that first 12 months there was a
chap in there called Tom Ponting and he
went over to he ended up getting to Opus
and you become a director there he sell
his own little business now he's a good
guy bloody good recruitment consultant
and all I did was just watch him really
it was quite a small little office all I
did was look at him and think what did
he what he did was he there it was like
top below and I joined so I just
observed him and and he wasn't doing
anything extraordinary you know he
wasn't some sort of boffin and you know
he was he was just doing a very job very
you know really simple and so I would
just look at him and watch what he was
doing and emulate what he was doing and
copy what he was doing mm-hmm and that's
pretty much how I then got through that
really is just like look at the
person who's making money copy them and
make it better
mmm and that's why what is a advice for
people that join your business now mmm
part of it part of it yeah I always says
more to it than that but I always think
I think I always say to somebody like
anybody joins our business now is just
like listen use your ears listen to
people within the office listen to when
they're doing what are they doing well
and what they're doing badly take a look
at the people that are at bottom of the
table what are they doing what they're
not doing yeah don't look at the person
who's doing really wait really really
well and also at the same time don't be
disheartened if you're not performing so
their level of say a top biller
yeah because you know he's taken him a
long time to get there it's tough it's
long game yeah and then how just on that
point on because it's come on quite a
lot now how did you naturally ask for
help what was you someone that naturally
would be go over to him and go you know
like you know we just did they're like
I'm struggling a bit with that you know
how you approach that bedico would be
great if you could talk to me a bit
about why you did that one yeah I really
did I look back I did yeah all of my
training was like on the job and so it
was it was like you know he's a he's a
job advert he's a job I want you to
write a job advert so you just do it and
you just get on with it and do all the
job there was no structured training for
me so I had to listen I had to pick up
and I hadn't I didn't sit next to
somebody listening I think I did it for
like a day or something ya know I just
always I always I'm the experiential
learner you know the moment you act an
activist base yeah yeah so I have to do
the job to deliver be able to learn I
just think that such an advice and it's
come up quite a lot now so like if
you're listening and you're struggling
right now and there's people around you
that you look up to to inspire you that
you think you can learn from then go go
over and ask go I know that can be
difficult content some songs because you
don't to be seen as like you did no one
likes to feel like they've they're
stupid or
I think there's a lot of there can be a
bit of ego in recruitment and there can
be a bit of too much pride that I think
people just need to loosen up a little
bit and just go to somebody's doing
really well and ask say looking at what
are you doing it's really Kyle is into
you for an hour you know can I can you
just tell me a few things that you're
doing especially if that works really
well with us because each recruitment
concerns got their own even though we do
the same market yeah
everyone's got their own location in
their own region mmm so we are a culture
and I've always created that as a
culture of sharing anyway hmm so look
you know if you're doing something
really well I want you to talk to
somebody about it what you tell somebody
about it yeah an advice a verse and make
sure that you ask and I think I think me
that's the way you learn isn't it yeah
we always learn by watching and
listening so just to help me out and the
people listen them what what's been your
sort of obviously obviously you own that
you own half of the business for the
last sort of seven or so years but like
what obviously I know that sort of your
role and what you've been up to is also
evolving
so I guess just just help me understand
sort of how it's got to the point where
now you're sort of heavily invested in
marketing and these types of things so
work talk to me about that says Klee
started as a biller was obviously doing
well when you had the Billings yeah then
did you start managing and building a
team underneath you or whatever just
sort of journey the okay so that there
wasn't any kind of clear-cut short
career structure for me there wasn't a
competency-based framework there was
something yeah add to follow everything
I've done since becoming like a direct
it was like I was I was directing as a
recruitment consultant I didn't have any
clear plans in front of me how I'm gonna
do it or anything along those lines of
goals anything like that I just had to
feel my way hmm so I you know I took -
right well I'm accruing so I need a
resource er I didn't even really
understand what a resource it was yeah
do not mean it as hi it's somebody to do
what the [ __ ] job basis yeah it's a beta
so I get a really good candidate what is
the kind of thing as well though with
can I go back a little bit because with
with when we were underneath Veridian
yeah and they were hiring for all the
banks there was a big change that happen
within the financial advice industry and
and what happened was it was a request
and called a retail distribution review
but anyway the consequences with that of
that were that the banks had to kick out
basically a lot of their financial
advisers they couldn't no longer hire
these ki-- please keep these financial
advisors hires because their model for
financial advice didn't suit the retail
distribution review well now because
they couldn't burn it they're like can't
bonus them as much anymore are they
can't give advice it was based around
how you how you charged for financials
the mission based or fee based exactly
the time so the bank's can really do
that so in that situation what you had
was all these financial advisors that
were working for the bank
were no longer working for the banks we
couldn't place them in so it's like well
all we ever knew was bancassurance
bancassurance so then we looked at well
what's the rest of the world out there
and it was IFA is it was well for
management always a smaller boutique so
we kind of visioned really that RDR was
can have an impact that was gonna have a
massive impact on the IFA and wealth
management market so we pulled away from
Veridian did no longer wanted to use
their branding or anything yeah and when
I took the directorship I said look
we're gonna do this we need to have our
own brand yeah I think we need to take
this recruit UK from a name on a piece
of paper and turn it into a bloody
company yeah and we need to start
looking at the IFA and wealth management
market and that's essentially what we
did so when I did that you had a couple
of people that were still having a foot
in the viridian making sure we're making
placements over there because that was
our bread and butter and I went off it's
completely cold into the world of IFA so
absolutely I had to completely
understand and brand-new a kind of brand
new market you know self-employed
advisers employed advisers
high-net-worth ones and all the
different types of advise advisers I had
to go out there and learn it all so that
was when I kind of got into him when I
got right into it how did you approach
that then cuz that that's probably a
real common thing that people ask about
how like marketing really yeah so it was
purely base of fact if I had a really
good candidate yeah yeah so let's say
for example you know you go on to read
back then and there'll be a load of
financial advisers that have been kicked
out the bank's there yeah yeah so I take
that candidate and I would go to market
so I would just take a really good
candidate pick up the phone and I'd
phone every single financial advice
company that was there and I'd sell that
candidate in a big part of what I did as
well as make sure I spoke to as many
candidates as possible and I just asked
them questions
mmm I mean something that people I don't
think do very well anymore is to learn
their market through asking candidates
and asking questions base it but it's so
it's come up so much it's the basics
yeah it's the absolute basics of
recruiting I think but I think for me
part part of that is like particularly
early on or whatever like you you get in
this or you know what you need to get
out that corn you sometimes you cannot
hurry to make sure you get what you need
to get out of if you get I mean you're
thinking about right I need to get this
out this cool rather than yeah you know
I'm even thinking about right what
questions kind of ask to get even more
information rather than I need to tick
off job titles so your expectation
locations travel blah blah blah do you
not I mean people are scared to ask a
question because they don't want to
sound silly yeah so true and it's like
there is and and the thing is there
you'll think when you're phoning up when
you're phoning up say a financial
advisor what do they like to do they
like to talk about themselves
yeah it's not mean so it's a thing as
well I haven't the humility to go you
know what Sam you know what you just
said that I'm not you I'm not I should
quite sure I understand that can you
tell me a bit more about that exact
guarantee you there's they're not gonna
go Sammy
you should know that but I say what I
say to everybody is ask ask a set amount
of questions to every candidate you
speak to you who knows let's say you've
got ten different candidates will
working for ten different companies if
you ask them what they liking what they
dislike about the current company
they're working for hmm because the next
person you speak to works for that
company you already know what they
prominently like it was particularly
nonsence what are those systems like Oh
a system to crap at the bonus is good no
oh yeah the bonuses so you just learning
as you go on in making a note and you're
just building up and what you know
building up an idea of your marketing
companies are good and the companies
aren't did you really start mapping out
your market and you candidates you know
what Sam actually I've had interviews
here interviews there blah blah blah so
I started doing that so I said Dean I
said map in the market and understanding
what these different propositions were
out there what a self-employed born was
what an employee born was tide
restricted IFA whatever it was and
really understood understood the market
it was just me covering the whole of the
UK I employed somebody as a resource so
I find some good candidates
I give him a candidate and I'd say write
your job today is just to phone every
single come back and then we started
building an email marketing database off
the back of it and specking candidates
out via email as you as you do
and then gradually that grew and over
time I would then hire somebody to say
why your job is to work that location
and your jobs to work that location now
we've got to this stage so I've got like
16 cruises now we've got another three
that we should be taking on accepted and
it's starting in January Wow so an ether
and we've got three regional teams
they've got a team that looks after the
southeast and London and team that's out
the Midlands and north and team looks
after the Southwest in Wales
why did you do it on geography out of
interest just I think it's just for us
it was easier to manage
yeah so you did it based on geography
and you kind of can then place a certain
amount of recruitment consultants within
a deal with innocence within the UK I
think that we were covering the UK then
as well
you know you're talking about their
light obviously gradually over time and
stuff mm-hmm how long did that take from
you going right we need some this is
there's a great opportunity here to take
these financial advisors are out of a
job into a market because I think again
in today's world it's so easy it's like
if I would to look into the window real
quick okay now and go bloody a sound
doing and right in here like what's
gonna happen only twenty people in his
business he's doing all right but like
what what was the sort of just for like
everyone's benefit what was a timeline
of you
recognizing that opportunity and then
building it from scratch to where it
actually being pretty profitable and
good well we were downstairs in this
little kind of fish tank window then you
literally look through our window
actually downstairs and it was a massive
amount of trial and error as I said to
you I didn't have any handbook I don't
have any guide I didn't have some mentor
telling me me or Stuart what to do we
basically feeling our way as we were
doing it so there was a period where it
was kind of run like you'd have one foot
in being a recruitment consultant and
the next foot in trying to be a director
and pushed the business fort yeah whilst
trying to pay the bills
yeah employees within there paying the
bills of where you weren't it's all new
to us really and yeah and it was quite
quite tough but we kind of assigned
roles quite early on stood quite like
the finances side and I quite like the
idea of pushing the business forward so
that was that was kind of my game really
but there was a there was a lot of time
there was a big period where I was
feeling my way hmm and we were running
it kind of like business owners and
recruiters and it was bit messy there
was no structure to it so I was going
for like three three years I think we've
been up we've been up so we moved
upstairs from bang stairs about three
years ago hmm and it was half this space
we've got now okay and then last year I
took over the rest of the half I always
said I'm gonna have those rooms cuz they
were they were vend
meeting rooms her I know this was
another meeting he was like I'm gonna
take over those rings I had a vision of
taking able to go and ended up take
taking him over and so I would say as a
business actually running it as a
business and thinking about the growth
of it and lot on the business yeah
having the structure within it because
it paid around with having different
people managing and you know setting the
business up in different ways and I know
it be settled on the regional side of it
but it took time to get there so
thinking like the last I would save
three years where it's been running
properly as a machine that I know
knowing they might bring somebody in I
can slot them anymore that's it's scary
available and he got competency based
framework and got great bonus structures
and we've got three years ago what's
that then like what we're talking two
free years up until the last three years
yeah that's such a good thing to make
sure everyone understands that like
you're not gonna have everything planned
out straight away and it doesn't happen
overnight do you know I mean I think
that's such an important thing to
highlight that and also the fact you've
been honest around that you're you're
working your way out and you know I mean
I hadn't you know what I'm not gonna lie
to you I was [ __ ] myself on a
regular basis
I was also resentful on a regular basis
why because it was like I just want this
sometimes you just want this because I
got into becoming a director when you
become director yang go and suck at the
right to salary right yeah when you
recruit mcclee so and you're only load
of money yeah you know and I was just I
was earning I was probably at that point
where I would have been yelling some
really good money yeah I've got on nice
holidays and all that good stuff and all
of a sudden I'd moved from being a
recruiting consult and all I had to
worry about was my sister Billings yeah
yeah then having to worry about building
a business without any experience or
anything like that but knowing I kind of
had an ego side of me that wanted to do
it I wanted to build it and you've
become a little bit Negi in a bit
resentful because any money that you get
in um the pains of somebody else's
pocket versus salary and I didn't really
get it and you're unsure and it's a so
it was hard it was really really really
hard during that period and I kind of
think like looking back on it I would
have taken some advice really yeah I
wish you feel like you could have gone
to anyone like was that even like an
option I didn't I oh yeah I suppose it
was I could have done that yeah but I I
I don't know it just didn't seem to
compute in my mind here's where as you
look at people now like can you look at
you guys he's just gonna mad yeah I'm
gonna company so I'm seeing being set up
you know they get backed by finances now
and all that kind of stuff
and if we're doing that probably back in
the day when it was but I just wasn't
I was I was quite I guess narrow-minded
a little bit a little bit like I'm gonna
do it I don't want anybody else to help
me so would your advice be them one I
never took investment we've never taken
investment hmm we've never had
investment but one of the piece of
advice potentially would be some seek
advice 100% yeah cuz it's hard work and
it's a time
because he as you said you were doing
loads of things you've never done before
yeah and everything I was doing I was
feeling out where is if I think you know
like James Osbourne in the recruiting
right if we'd have done something like
that earlier I think we would have had a
game plan yes I would have got my game
plan a lot earlier and stuck to a game
plan a lot earlier because there are
people out there who've done this job
tried and tested it and forged a good
path whereas I was just forging my own
path yeah you know I wasn't really
listening to anybody else so it's just
forging my own path there wasn't a thing
was an arrogance I think it's because I
was just super super busy hmm and always
say you're kind of thinking oh my god
how much is it gonna cost and you always
try to keep costs low and all that stuff
and so what what was some of the key
learnings do you think then during that
period if you were to again think back
before you got to the point where you're
really focused on on the business how
the structures are at structure and
place like what are some of the key
learnings do you think that people can
communication is key it's with who
people internally or just with your
business partner really make sure that
you both know what each person's
responsibility is hmm I think looking
back on that it was quite loose mmm we
didn't have we were quite loose people
in a sense of our what we were trying to
hope to gain from it new universe have
really communicated that properly I said
first I would definitely say make sure
you don't fill her in to then like the
consultants of stuff of you and Stewart
won't accompany on the same page yeah I
guess so
yeah I suspect that probably might well
have happened over time you become more
attuned to each other and what each
person is responsible for because again
you know when you're a small business
and when you were the one it say for
example someone's looking after the
financial side of the business and in
your head you're looking after the
growth of the business yeah they're two
very separate roles yeah you know one's
a sales role one's like keeping the ship
together yeah and then but I'll be
honest with you I wasn't a massive fan
of the management side of it I really
struggle with managing people really
because I'm two directs and you'll get
[Laughter]
to realize that do you think scrap that
right I'm not a bad manager okay I'm
just very honest and I'm very direct and
yeah but as you said some people don't
like so much oh yeah I just some people
I think some people don't like it
because I think some people the
days and getting into recruitment I'll
which are sensitive hmm and I think it's
not the kind of mark it's not the kind
of job it used to be like and you know I
think you can be a lot you have to be
very careful how you speak to people
nowadays and I'll tell you get what you
mean I guess some people don't like to
be told that they're doing something
wrong mmm you know they get a little bit
negative
mmm whereas I'm quite capable of sitting
down with something if someone's not
doing well my strength is I will sit
down with them and I will tear apart
their desk mmm and I'll do it in a
consultative way but I'm not very
sensitive to somebody's emotions around
it yeah so that's you can see why that
has 100 percent because if someone said
to me on my SATs you talking so and then
talking about learnings communication
challenge so you'll see you through that
process you worked at you wasn't
obviously the your management starred in
obviously clip of everyone no not with
everyone though definitely so what were
some of the other challenges through
that period were thinking about or
talking about that you think people
could benefit from how you manage your
personal stress hmm and your health and
well-being because are we talking from a
recruitment becoming a recruiter or
becoming a director of a business or
both you yeah if that's what you chant
that the people are other people gonna
be experiencing that if you experienced
that I think we I think recruitment as a
whole is a very tough job yeah mentally
a tough job and then your podcast is
called the recruitment rollercoaster you
are literally up and down on a daily
basis and I think if you are struggling
perhaps with your if you are struggling
with your mental health during those
periods or health in general it can be a
really real drain on drain on you
basically your energy levels everything
like that so my advice to anybody within
recruitment or getting into it is to and
macey when I was a bit like it is just
look after yourself look after the year
look after your health look under your
well-being
you know I nowadays back then I would
just if I had a good day
I get smashed if I had a bad day I'd get
smashed in the weekend would come I get
I was just always getting on it Basin
was getting drinking yeah and then when
you know what that's like you're up and
down with that you get hangover they
merge all together when you're doing a
stressful job it then becomes even worse
because like that low is a low in the
highs are high and they so these days I
do a lot more we like my name I don't
drink alcohol or anything like that
complete teetotaler really yeah
completely how long last 7-bit months oh
wow yeah it's taking a long time for me
to get there but I'm a complete
teetotaler now but the difference to how
I am now in this job it doesn't have a
have such a negative effect on me if I
get stressed out I can really on bit
calm I'm a lot calmer I look at things
outside of work like yoga and I was
meditating before you turned up
meditation I do I love my running you
know I love exercise and all that type
of stuff so I think how how has that
been how is that then benefited you and
as a as a recruitment you know I ret to
Harmar yeah you make decisions without
being so rash with your decisions you
think about things more you're a bit
more patient you know you you're more
patient with people around you yeah
and ultimately you the the stresses in
the strings of running a company and
building your business don't overtake
your life and that you can just place it
as part of your part of your life and
then it doesn't invade my personal space
my wife my kid you know whereas before
it was just like eating into every
avenue of my life really
yeah god yeah you worry impacted your
personal relationship every relationship
I've had it's impacted really oh god
yeah massively it was always did you
find it hard to leave work at the door
then when you like yeah yeah so you know
picking up the phone when you're at home
thinking about when you go to bed
thinking about the weekend you know it
can really really play on you and that's
why I think you should really work on
your yourself your self your personal
well-being your mindset how you cope
with your problems I you know not
letting things build up communication
and communication and a hundred percent
because I think again is a lot of pride
in there's a lot of ego and McCrimmon
and I've been subject to that I didn't
want someone to know that Irish drug
or anything lines but now I talk to
people I let them know like my good
really good relationship with Stuart
where we open up to each other and make
sure we we know nothing it's again I
couldn't I couldn't grieve you more this
is something I'm super passionate about
I think obviously lon I will see not as
my obviously your you've been in the
journey longer than me but last five
months do my own thing that's just me I
was something that all was always quite
health-conscious mmm
always made the time to go to the gym he
is well as good but always the hannam
sempre percent ended up getting personal
that standard mmm but definitely what
I've experienced in the last four or
five months is it definitely has been
more challenging to akin it could be
excuses but it's definitely be more
challenging to have that balance of
making time for me and invest in myself
and yeah lie it definitely I've
definitely slapped on Jim these types of
things and I think yeah the you can very
much put all your eggs in the business
basket when it's your own thing it's
managing your expectations as well
because you're an ambitious person
she'll watch some of your videos and see
what you're a bow and you're a hawk so
yeah you know and I think when you put
yourself out there in the limelight on
LinkedIn as well you almost become a bit
of a mini celebrity so you an
expectation on yourself and a pressure
upon yourself to deliver and I think we
all will actually have that and it's
like are we being fair to ourselves so
true are we giving ourselves enough time
to recover from those unns
and and all that kind of stuff and I
think you know I think it's just make
sure you give yourself plenty of time
mmm I think that that's definite one
thing I realize it's that will actually
big part of the reason why I wanted to
start my own business was see I have
more flexibility in my life and these
types of things and that means that for
me I - yeah have more weeks where there
we the type of weeks that I want rather
than yeah to cater to my clients right
and stuff like that yeah but I think
just as well just to I think again you
have to be honest with this stuff like I
did a post recently about yeah like you
off see I'm you experienced this in your
life but also review having your own
business a very easy small talk question
is awesome how's business
mmm like you get that like 10 times more
when when you don't work for someone
obviously the typical small chat is
awesome how's work mate but when it's
your own business little Sam how's
business how's it going it's going well
blah blah blah and I'm still really
experienced that and like this obviously
some people that do you ask you that
question for me there's some people that
like even if I was struggling and it was
a really tough time they were people
there would be people that asked me that
question I wouldn't want to have a
conversation with them they struggling
yeah so there's part of that that you'll
just want to back off in a yes great
there's also a big part in today's world
we don't talk about like the bad times
which is why I've shared in my post
light it's just so important to me to be
honest which is why one of the things I
shared was one of the bit challenges
I've had is like for me because it's um
I'm wearing I don't you don't have
anyone celebrate wins with and they're
having a challenge which I've been used
to yeah so I think I'm glad you're
sharing that because it's so important
to be honest and all this sort of stuff
it can be very lonely even you've got a
team of people because you don't want to
tell your employees you're having a hard
time exactly you want to be seen as
being that guys like on it and leading
by example and all many types of things
you hold a lot of that sort of stuff and
even when you've got a team of people
around you when you're on your own
yeah I can imagine it's even even more
difficult yeah just bending your missus
here or your partner's here but yeah
that's what my final point sort of on
this around what you're talking about
and sharing is that again it comes down
to communication that's something that
I've had to really work on in my own
relationship the this or the girlfriend
I have is someone I wanna be with the
rest of my life and I know like for me
what I've had to really be clear with
which I wasn't so good with previously
was communicating so let me meet yes
sometimes I may have to stay a bit late
or whatever but that's because this is
what I'm trying to build for us and all
that and actually before I was very
prone to just like leave me alone I'm
working like Bank on rather than
communicating why I'm why I'm doing this
one less effort into it because there's
an yeah I'm communicating that this is
for us and yeah it's like you can very
easily not communicate that like you
were saying that you just thought you
probably just take those phone calls
look I need to do it yeah I need to do
this but you need to communicate why
you're doing it and with your partner as
well that's what I've found when you're
under a low depression stress yes I mean
it's communicating what yeah what you're
doing this for because a lot of the time
either you've sometimes think as people
understand why you're doing
this is Mike this blonde half this
business well I need to do this so ma'am
why are you why are you doing it there
let me ask any questions for you know
but why are you doing it what is your
washing for me yeah honestly there's
something that asked that question to
myself sometimes it's different every
time you know what I think and have I
got a complete concrete answer to that
probably not yeah I think for me what
I'm full of my gut instinct and where my
guy instincts is always sort of led me
to is what I've become really passionate
about just with the journey I've been on
it is helping others and those sounds
Papa cliche I like it but that's what's
probably always driven me and I found my
position found that sort of myself in a
position where sort of what I've ended
up doing for myself and what I've learnt
along the wake and there's actually I've
can actually help a lot of people hmm
and I think that's just that's just what
really gets me going
and it's that so just that that's sort
of always driven me really if I think
about what I did now and going into
businesses and meeting people in and
that this podcast has definitely labeled
that as well I think that that's when I
feel most alive and sort of really
buzzed off that and that's what's true
but that's the drive really so you drive
is to help other people and I think now
at the moment is a perfect time to
become that teacher and I think
everybody anybody out there who's decent
their job of becoming those influences
and they call them an influencer don't
they or they become a teacher hmm and
they're you know it's about educating
your clients candidates around how to do
things better and how I can help you do
these things better and I I found that
myself
by doing this digital recruitment
solutions inside of our business and
about when I go into these companies and
I understand the struggles that they're
experienced in respective hiring say
financial planners in a in a market that
which is very advice it's just are
moving and there aren't that many of
them and I'm educating them and telling
them about the struggles we come up
against is one of the largest financial
planning recruiters in the UK they start
to listen a little bit you know and I
start to tell him a little bit about the
struggles what we you know how we do
things what we should know what we're
doing and how marketing impacts that and
you know trying to educate them that you
don't stand out
you didn't stand out in the marketplace
because that's always when I go into
businesses that's always one of the key
challenges that in all my all sectors
and markets is that the client will come
to you as a recruiter and go look Sam I
need you to head on or I need you to get
the best person the next superstar out
of our competitors mm okay Sam tell me
about sort of what you offer more than
the salary and these types of things and
you go well well for 20 days holiday or
stuff you know I mean it's like well
guess what Sam your competitor offers
that - yeah what's your differentiator
and these types of things yeah I mean so
that's such a common challenge that
would be across all sectors yeah and now
and again recruiters will be having
those conversation on a daily basis so
let's just talk a bit about that then so
obviously last three years you've often
now had the opportunity to really focus
on on on the business yeah and you've
obviously you've gone got to position
when you're planned to your strengths
which has been as we're talking about
being a bit of a journey is to get to
that point I'm quite on I've always had
a fondness for marketing mmm and looking
at ways to combine marketing with
recruitment you know for my clients and
the thing that I've the massive thing
that I've noticed is they don't clients
are willing to pay a lot of money for
contingency based fees because only pay
when they get there when they get the
result yeah but they're like when times
are hard they're like well why don't you
find him in anybody he said well and
again it goes that's that problem you're
not really standing out you're just
another company out there in the noise
and there's a huge amount of noise out
there of unbranded job adverts you know
every one client you know I'm
representing a wealth management firm
and ponerse you know they're they're not
thinking about their their the long-term
impacts that their brand around
recruitment is there isn't having hmm so
what I have done over the last nine
months is that I've immersed myself in
becoming a digital marketer hmm so I
taught myself everything about digital
marketing to be able in the very
beginning was to be able to just
recruit UK brand out there and to try to
generate some inbound leads I started
creating him by recruitment strategies
using hub spawning pages you know Google
Adwords sponsoring adverts on Facebook
and all that type of stuff and when I
started doing and I start to get some
results it was like well how can I now
do this for my clients and how long was
that period that because I think this is
clearly something that everyone's
talking about it's the world that I'm in
yeah how let's just make that crystal
clear cuz that's all wait that's always
a conversation around this isn't it and
that's the conversation always had with
people like you is little sound this is
a long-term investment it's like
building a recruitment business brand it
does take time of course but let's just
make that crystal clear from your
experience from deciding there and we
need to get the real quick' brand out
there marketing is important we need to
get that right there what was that
period of where you and you know what
we're actually get some good results
here and now how can I do is for my
clients how long was that period you
think really quick really yellow say
like three months really so I went bad
that is at ninety days yeah so I went
from like whack in it you know I went
from looking at what we can do for us as
yeah as a company get our brand out
there got the process in place for that
but I used an external marketing agency
team to manage it for me yeah I didn't
do all of that yeah yeah and then once I
did that I then saw the opportunity to
be able to say to my clients a couple of
clients that were struggling to find
candidates that let me why don't we take
your brand use your brand but sell it
through my my channel you know
essentially you know so if we're getting
10,000 hits a month on our website right
let's look at what you're getting oh
you're getting six thousand hits every
six months yeah
is it and we're doing all this work on
SEO to drive financial advisors to us
let's start marketing your brand to to
my followers essentially to my website
built leverage build leverage exactly
that so at that point you is kind of
like well I just sort of casually
mentioned Tom's like a couple guys are
gonna see some clients in casually
mentioned this is what we're doing would
you be interested and then when I went
along to some meetings with some of the
clients of ours and started saying what
we do is we create some blogs for you
and those blocks will be branded
we'll be talking about something
interesting within the financial advice
industry but we put your name in there
this is a feature you and all that kind
of stuff so we started doing that and it
was like well we're gonna create a
landing page on our website it's all
branded up so anything that someone
reads and then wants to click through
they'll land on there and watch a video
of you yeah there'll be a download on
there so we started creating downloads
then I thought well I'll just create a
package so you get you get this you get
that you get you know this is what you
get and it's now much you gonna charge
on a monthly basis and at that point I
thought if I'm gonna work with these
types of companies that are struggling
as hell to find candidates they're gonna
need to pay me because I'm I'm I'm
giving so much of my energy trying to
help them build build a business but I'm
only getting paid on a contingency basis
all right so it doesn't make any sense
yeah and recruitment is without a doubt
changing I think if you're gonna you
know contingency based recruitment will
always be there contract based
recruitment always be there but there's
this little bit in between now which is
this pie called digital recruitment
solutions which is charge all clients a
fee per month to be able to advertise
their brand to your following that you
spend loads of money on generating the
unloads and money on building and you
know and creating a huge audience my you
know their advert for example or their
blog article that we're gonna write this
will be really interesting for the
audience to read that we hopefully get a
load of readers on it and might click
through to their website whatever you
know it's cost me a shitload of money to
generate that audience they might go
it's like 85,000 first connections on an
organic basis totally on my stick a
thousand pound on it to to advertise on
Facebook or web mmm no and do some
target marketing and how is that being
received in your market now good yeah
yeah so I've got a couple of so this is
the cool thing really right say you know
I'm charging them on a monthly basis on
a 12-month contract so they have to do
12 months with current revenue well yeah
boy I was just continuing exactly and
then also on top of that I get full fees
mmm so you know you take it bring on a
couple of clients and you're earning
well over a hundred thousand pounds just
off of the recurring income and then
you've gotten there yet
yeah and obviously also what you're
doing there is obviously the problem
that we're the problem that where this
will came from is that they yeah they
can't stand out they obviously you can
you have the attention and these thing
which is what they don't have use your
audience basically yeah use your
audience but obviously the problem
you're solving is is that piece where
it's like okay so I've got five
financial
of companies or whatever and they're all
the same like what makes exactly so the
problem that I've I have an encounter
yeah is they want results I had a lot
quicker yeah and I'm like look it take
me it takes time to be sort of building
a relationship with you guys and our
audience so we could have built that
we've got a bill to how do you manage
the expectations each month I do review
with them I I go over what the
performance of that article or download
is and yeah what we've generated and we
look over the into interviews that we've
generated with them yeah I talk to them
you know about what we're gonna do next
month all that kind of stuff and what
you I found this that as I'm going
through each month because I'm
generating content that is out there in
Google for example the ranking in Google
and some of them ranked on page one of
Google yeah they're every month they're
getting more views more views like a
month one they might even it got 500
views but there are months sick all of a
sudden they're getting like 4000 views
and content with their name on it yeah
you know and I guess the thing got to
seem more direct they see more direct
applications which does mean injustice I
don't get however that's a huge value
added I just you know if I can if I can
add and this is the theme and if I can
just add the marketing said the
recruitment marketing services for them
and it costs this much money yeah if
they get things on a direct basis I'm
kind of ok with that because I make I'm
still making money out of out of it yeah
cool I wouldn't have made anyway
something yeah yeah your soul mate
you're you're actually you're adding an
actual real value to that business
you've been a real asset if you have 10
10 clients all taken out digital
recruitment solutions I've been you know
you know be like an 800 grandiere biller
you know so happy days it's interesting
that it works if it will get our guess
for you as well obviously like obviously
that came from you
I don't want to say too much because I
you know my competitors the thing is
mate look you could you could talk about
you can share your secrets how many
people are gonna take action and do it
and it's all and again it's about your
it's about understanding that you have a
niche market and just working at niche
market there's nobody in my niche market
in recruitment doing what I'm doing and
everybody in McCrimmon is working
their own little nishan though exactly
you know just and also from a digital
perspective so let's say so I'm looking
at hiring into this is what I gonna be
doing next year I'm if I look at some if
I wanted all of a sudden do a cyber
security desk yeah
and it's a cyber because a guy at ran a
corner he's been in 200 grand a year
doing cyber security yeah on a
contingency basis yeah yeah I'd say
around some say come in join me and I'll
wrap digital marketing recruitment
solutions around you and your desk how
many clients of yours will buy it
hmm well I reckon probably fought for
people to be interested well that's 250
gap grand of income straightaway and you
can still make contingency based fees on
top of it with them that'd be of
interest to you
and with a sudden it's like well no
one's speaking to me about this you know
if I'm going to recruiter I'm getting in
support and different no one's speaking
about what they're doing on the on a
market ask you you spit you speak of
Scylla I sit down and have this
conversation you speak to anyone around
the future recruitment future-proof your
business these sorts of things and a big
part of that a section of that
definitely is providing real solutions
that isn't pay pay for each person that
we place in each bomb and see do you
know I mean that and that's where that
stem from it's like do you get what I
mean yeah and you managing the
expectations of these clients go back to
go get going back to that you can't make
guarantees it's not like a like an RPO
or something like that it's not one RPO
you know sangs like it almost but it's
not you've gotta turn around and say I
can't guarantee placements into your
business but I can give you is some
feedback on how many people are seeing
your brand over what you're doing on
your own recruitment page so I logged
into that one of my clients pages and
they had like I made more add more views
of content in a month than they had all
year
so it's kind of like you're getting
value here the content is getting out
there people we phone somebody out
speech them about that client oh yeah
I've seen some of that stuff I've seen
I've seen I've seen the articles it's
really good you know they get more
direct applicants there's more things
for them to talk about it's just it's
better content for us to share through
the other recruitment consultants as
well cuz we do that we share across
because how does all of this just to
sort of finalize this how how how is
that how has that empowers that enabled
your recruiters to work like has that
impacted sort of what your recruiters do
with these businesses has it been easier
for them to recruit for them or you know
I mean has it enabled them to get more
traction
and for other consultants that have been
working on these account
yeah it's how you use the content so if
you create a little bit of content and
you go out and send a message via savory
I've got a self-employed proposition in
central London what another one yeah you
know instead it's like hey great lead
with how are you doing look got a recent
article about how to attract high net
worth individuals it's a really good
document put together I don't even have
a quick look at it so if they click on
it and go oh Britney land on there and
they start seeing some stuff about
foster de novo on there yeah it's just
another different type of angle and a
different type of conversation piece is
you using the all this or digital assets
that you're creating to engage with
candidates and I think that's about 100
seminars or it's about who's that
content and last not too weak in the
last two weeks I've decided to just be a
social seller I myself just to see how
good having content is to be able to
draw somebody in you know it's amazing
you know I just got onto someone
something like we've been in financial
advice right I find all the female
people women that were in financial
advice and I'll put an article on there
around something that's relevant towards
them and they'll click on the article
and they'll send me a message because
I'm asking them to feature on a blog
that I'm going to do next year around
females in financial advice and then
bang you got a conversation piece
because you're talking about something
that isn't I've got a job you know
you're talking about something giving
interest to them and I got a lot of
inbound leads from it and you send the
message via LinkedIn LinkedIn recruiter
send some content send something of
interest to them yes that that's my
whole thing with it and also this is
what I do for a living now and that
that's my whole thing of it obviously
that the whole girl will do more on
LinkedIn and sharing your opinion is
obviously we want to drive more people
coming to you because I can see Sam are
why he knows what he's talking about
however huge thing for me which what I
do for my self and why you should do
when in my previous job was used the
people that are engaged in the content
and these types of things to actually
drive sales conversations so if I put a
post out there round yeah woman in
financial advice and Susie comments on
that send Sam this is really interested
in like thanks for sharing well guess
what if I was number one on a call and
say hi Susie Fenton engage in my content
you might see non trying to do more in
LinkedIn and by the way you know what we
do here to recruit UK and you can also
do that in a message and I guarantee you
that's going to drive results and it's
gonna
you to have more of an opportunity to go
hi Susie this is why we're different
that's what a lot of recruiters need
these days because in the day something
to make him stand back yeah someone
makes them stand out but just recruits
need more of that opportunities to go
this is why we're different do you know
I'm in because then the day a candidate
or client right now they probably have
the perception they know what you're
doing who you want you're not any
different every everybody I'm talking to
you about this for creeping solutions if
they can't afford it and I'm gonna make
it affordable for everyone next year and
it's gonna be affordable for everybody
mmm even if they don't I think they
think I've it's a bit risky that they're
all interested mmm they will just think
they can all see the benefit in it you
don't see the benefit of of branded
advertising on a regular basis with good
cut strong content that's gonna annoy a
traffic to them they're just you know
it's it's do you think a big part of
this that's helped you get to this point
is that you didn't come from a typical
recruitment background don't know I
guess so maybe but then again sometimes
I think that might have been a little
bit of a disadvantage yeah of course
because I I must admit you know I'd like
to have been part of the team like you
know recruitment team and you know it's
not I mean yeah a bit of a ladder and
recruitment although I think I would
quite night there's a lot of creepin
consultants I hang around with a lot
younger hmm and you know I look at what
they're up to in their business I mean
it's great and I didn't really have that
yeah you know I've just been nuts into
running a business I didn't have that
little bit in between mm-hmm so kind of
like a little bit like that would have
been really really nice but at the same
time I just haven't really ever stopped
trying to evolve yeah so then just a
quick one they'll be like I'm sure
you've seen the stats out there but
there's loads of stats out there to back
up the majority their UK recruitment
market is sort of sub ten staff you're
more than that
so again subtends yeah so like there's
loads of stats out there I mean there's
loads of stats out there run sort of 70
or 80 percent of the UK recruitment
market employing the 10 star really yeah
yeah okay so what what's been because I
think again people listening I think the
sort of value that you can have an
experience you've been and how how
what's been your journey and hiring
people for your business what's that
been like and what are some of the sort
of learnings around that cuz I think
that's always a huge challenge for a lot
of people trial and error
I don't think there's any magic formula
for hiring big billers or the right
white people but what are some of the
sort of key I guess the the during this
period of building this business like
what they solve non-negotiables in terms
of hiring people for your business there
we're finding now yeah that we're
focusing more we didn't focus on the
grad market I really so something now
that we're starting to focus on
graduates okay so why is that of
interest why didn't we know there's what
how come you're going spend a bit more
time more thinking about because of
their ads and like we quite like their
attitudes okay and we like the fact that
they don't know anything about the
industry and they haven't been tainted
by another company your work didn't
sales or anything like that so you can
kind of mold them to how you want them
to be yeah but also they have a kind of
drive I think when they leave University
or some do not everybody to want to earn
money and there's a natural
competitiveness to outperform friends
who've got other jobs in everything yeah
but also there's a bit of debt there as
well and they want to prove to people
[ __ ] up into you yeah anything I need to
go and get some money to earn some money
my dad need to be proud of me yeah
there's an element of that there and I
just think they just they do no no it's
not putting anybody I think is I didn't
I wasn't the ground I just got 16 so
it's like that's just been your recent
experience Oh what's work I just I think
we you know we're seeing more grounds
and we're using more we're using a wreck
to wreck agency mmm whereas we didn't do
that before hmm
so when you didn't have a great time you
can someone brought for your door you
take a pun on somebody because you think
and I didn't really want enough to do
all this again and spend all this time
and energy and recruiting what I'm
trying to build a business at the same
time so um you know does that make sense
yeah yeah culture yeah cool job such a
big topic is it but I've I thought I
mean it's a topic that I mean if you're
in a business the culture at the busy
area
I think it's always an interesting one
is obviously there's such a vast topic
but cleaning important one there's
crema misses out there like do you think
you have a union culture I think we do
hmm
sometimes I think it's a little bit too
late back
we've always allow people to pretty much
work their way that they want to work
and we haven't ever been that start work
at seven finish at 7:30 8 o'clock type
mentality and we've been quite loose
around that yeah because I think it's my
means to it quite like our lives outside
of work because if we want other people
to experience that as well but you want
those people to work really hard within
that short period of time core so that's
kind of like that looseness and allowing
people to be themselves but at the same
time people kind of don't need that
people need a little bit of structure
within the culture how long how long do
you think it's taken you to sort of
build this sort of recruit UK culture
yeah so he's kind of I think it's got
and it's become it's always evolving yes
sure
it's always evolving it's always change
it's always changing because like is it
just a constant process of you working
out what yeah someone yeah I think
someone because again you want to be
light yes you want people to come and
work for you so you talk about things
that you think that they want you know
so you're thinking like you know
flexible flexible working hours mobile
phones you know Netflix nettle health
problems or anything like that we've got
a king so you can phone and we've always
been like that and we are we are a
company's open honest fair you know we
don't create this horrible
competitiveness in here and we don't
have a beer culture drunk culture or
anything like that we try not to create
that kind of classic white white boy
type man recruitment it yes we're not
into that and we never really have been
mmm not to say we don't have a laugh and
go out and have a good craic people in
here do but we just don't encourage it
yeah a bar in here or anything like yeah
I might make you stand out there mate
what I like people to it's like okay
right say creeps pretty stressful yeah
you want some time to go to the gym at
lunch well yeah I'd love that
well maybe go to yoga yeah I love that
then we do that yeah make your time up
at the end of the day
you know it's but you know she'll
responsibility it's your you've still
got to make some billions because at the
end of the day if you don't make any bit
into your job and that's the reality of
isn't it what do you think mate what do
you think of some of the key things the
sort of a tribute to making a great
recruitment and today as well make
obviously a lot of things have changed
and will continue to change in your time
in sort of the real criminal world what
what makes some of the best recruiters
in your business do or I think it's
about going back to basics hmm so I know
this is pretty cliché cliché maybe you
might have heard it a few times but to
make it right now you've got to do what
other people aren't doing and what
people aren't doing right now is the
basics that people did ten years ago
which is pick up that telephone go out
and meet people on a face-to-face basis
build relationships yeah stop looking at
what others are doing mmm and start
doing mmm does that make sense yes
certainly don't hide behind LinkedIn
don't hide behind the email don't hide
behind what sir these are all incredible
tools that can aid and help you but they
will absolutely rinse your time you know
nothing is more effective I believe than
having a good conversation with somebody
certainly having a good chair is hardly
so it's about hungry more if you were
getting some recruitment just get make
yourself a son come do the most
uncomfortable thing which is pick that
phone up and speak to people to ask
people questions like we were saying
earlier yeah really build that
relationships with your audience
understand what them what people are
talking about because people are far
more honest over a telephone call with
you or a face-to-face with you than they
would be sending a little message or
heavenly so quick and so short at the
moment it absolutely works brilliant can
get always somebody I watch that for
whatever but I think yeah you need to be
to make it right now just just do other
people aren't doing I think 80% of
people are just simply to show you hide
behind an email hide behind an email you
know absolutely and I think um go back
to those basics and sales you know learn
some goddamn sales you know it's
understand how to ask open questions
close questions and features and
benefits all the things that we kind of
you can forget a little bit mmm
Marketing and everything like that is
massively important in this day and age
you know absolutely you need to have a
good strong presence out there so
absolutely you look at what your
competitors are doing and try to stand
out so again what you do I think it's
great I don't be afraid to get yourself
on video and put some content out there
yeah but the thing is I think it's come
back to your initial point it's that
there I think aidid with all the things
that you can do in today's world yeah I
think if you really combine both but
yeah I think you're absolutely nail it
you can procrastinate really easy and
recruitment mmm it's because there's so
much and it's not as simple it's not
like he's a you know sometimes you kind
of want someone to give you a hundred a
list of 100 names and say make a hundred
phone calls I mean like a say simple but
mmm okay I guarantee you at the end of
that hundred calls you make you've got
some some business yeah you know I mean
if a people are scared to do that now
because well I've sent her I've sent a
thousand messages on in barrels and it's
like yeah like every other Tom Dick and
Harry slip before we finish mate recruit
UK mm-hmm where where's this where's
this going mate we're going yeah weird
where where would you like to see the
business and there's copy or what would
you see what do you see on the horizon
and this recruitment world in respective
recruit UK where I see us going is about
growing so we are hiring in McGrane
we're going next year so we're aiming to
take on sort of 15 people next year oh
wow yeah so there's nothing what gets 22
favored yeah this is enough business for
us to really dominate our niche well
continue on with the digital marketing
to support it to get our brand out there
as much as we possibly can and start to
really work with clients closer on their
digital recruitment solutions mmm so
that's where the big play for you guys
this plan just what you say digital
recruitment solutions and continue to be
niche don't I'm you know I'm not there's
so much business for us to go after we
don't need to go anywhere ice solution
II didn't dominate you just need to
dominate our niche yeah and stick and
stick to that and not me sort of skewed
by and perhaps a little bit something a
bit shiny some warehouse
just have the confidence that right just
build a really good recruitment company
in that market and be known as the look
that goes to Xers and what do you think
people should be thinking about in 2020
and beyond in the recruitment yeah what
do you think people should be thinking
about from a real criminal perspective
going into nexium and beyond what they
should be thinking about yeah individual
recruiters yeah they should be thinking
about what motivates them nice what
motivates them hmm
so aniline what motivates you align your
goals basically say whatever your
financial goals or whatever your
personal goals goals are aligned
yourself to it and be true and stick to
it and that's what I think they should
be thinking about and they should be
thinking about like I said before just
going back to basics you know can i how
many more people can I speak to you know
should I confront people like I mean you
don't have to go meet people anymore
face to face but I might do I have a
great time yeah and I learned a lot less
so get back to basics basically in 2020
because there's a lot of dipsticks out
there doing it you know a real it's a
simple job it's a simple job in it yeah
it's a simple job you know complicated
by by ideas written Sulur last question
I think you just touched on it there but
sorry what are you excited about mate am
i excited about yeah what were you
excited about I'm personally whatever
yeah just excited about I'm really
excited about Christmas right now yeah
and spending you with my daughter
spending it with my wife having complete
and utter clarity around enjoying a
Christmas without getting pissed up and
love me ed or anything like that and
really being closer to my family I'm
going to my brothers I'm really looking
forward to that I'm incredibly grateful
for everything that I have mmm
right now and I'm very well-connected if
you like to that positive energy it's
amazing and like I've had a really
really good like final part this year
and like next year I'm so blessed if you
like and happy take him to move into
that into a new year in
in a real move that mine Haza to mine
set by that I've worked really really
hard to achieve and and from a business
perspective you know I just want to get
a load of good guys in it I want to get
a lot of mobile fish or girls yeah
anybody you know I'm just gonna get guys
and girls in here who were happy
motivated want to make money get that
make sure that we can bed that digital
marketing solutions into some more
companies and establish ourselves as
being the number one financial planning
recruitment company in the UK it's
exciting Matt yeah Sam it's been a
pleasure
cheers buddy thank you